people sometimes come up to me after I
give talks they say oh tell me about
your methodology and I i really wish i
had a good answer to that you know it's
kind of like well I walk around and I
look at things and I read a lot and when
I find out about an interesting personal
sometimes try to interview them
particularly if I can come up with an
article and I and I sleep on it quite
literally I get a lot of the synthetic
ideas well I'm asleep or in that sort of
twilight zone and and the process of
writing actually helps too because just
as somebody who does mathematical
modeling has to sit down and actually
take their vague notion and to turn it
into equations in the case of me writing
while I take you know I usually start
with some sort of intuition and then I
refine it and while I'm actually sitting
there I'll have other ideas and I'll
realize oh that doesn't really logically
follow what about this what about that
um I look for interesting academic
research I which is heart often hard to
find because if you don't have a
popularizer who've already pays all
ready popularized into how do you find
it it's easier for me within the world
of economics because I know a lot of
economists I wrote in a can economics
column for The New York Times for six
years and I over the course of doing
that I learned like but I've learned to
how to do it in other fields and you
know you follow footnotes you read an
interesting book it has footnotes you go
look up the things that they're
footnoted I read a lot of history I'm I
think that we have a tremendous amount
to learn about the president in the
future from studying the past not just
in the sense of where we got here but in
less sort of linear sense of analogy and
inspiration and and synthesis
Oh